Tag 81 von Putins Krieg in der Ukraine
und auch heute wollen wir uns die
militärische Situation angucken wollen
uns angucken was im Osten der Ukraine
bei dieser mega Offensive die
mittlerweile seit sechs Wochen läuft die
russische mega Offensive denn passiert
als allererstes wollen wir uns noch mal
die militärische Lage angucken der Krieg
hat sich ja sehr in den Osten verlagert
in die Region hakiv im Norden hier
Lugansk im Osten und Donetsk im Süden
und das erste Video was wir uns angucken
wollen ist aus der Nähe von severo netzc
aus der Stadt Rubigen eine Stadt um die
Wochen lang verbissen gekämpft wurde und
das Videomaterial was jetzt sozusagen
hier reingekommen ist ist ziemlich
einmalig es zeigt nämlich diesen
Häuserkampf es zeigt eine Position eine
ukrainische Position in der Stadt wo
zwei Soldaten hier einfach direkt um
sich herum überall russische Kämpfer
haben im Hintergrund sehen wir ein
zerstörtes Haus und die beiden versuchen
eben die russischen die russischen
Vormarsch hier abzuhalten man hört das
Gewehr vor man hört die Explosion man
sieht auch gleich hier im Hintergrund
wie eine erste Granate sofort einschlägt
in dem in dem Haus unter ihnen und wir
spüren das einfach mal ein bisschen vor
und und sehen uns an was gleich passiert
denn so sieht es kurzzeitig aus das
letzte Stundenplan dieser beiden hat
geschlagen es gibt eine Granaten
Explosion die direkt neben dieser
Stellung erfolgt wir sehen das glaube
ich in eine Sekunden und man geht schon
davon aus da ist es passiert das ist das
Ende diese beiden sind jetzt sozusagen
tot glücklicherweise ist es nicht
passiert sondern es gab ja sie sind
wahrscheinlich verletzt diesen
schockiert aber sie machen weiter also
man kann sich das wirklich kaum
vorstellen überall um sie herum
russische Kämpfer russische Soldaten und
diese beiden versuchen hier weiterhin
ihre Positionen zu verteidigen und
der eine Soldat der das ganze hier filmt
mit seiner hingestellten Kamera stellt
sie tatsächlich wieder hin und versucht
hier weiterzumachen der hintere Soldat
versucht auch weiterhin zu schießen und
die letzte Sache die wir sehen und das
will ich noch mal festhalten ist das was
ich jetzt mal ein Kreise
der Soldat bereitet hier eine
Handgranate vor und diese Handgranate
wirft ja auch gleich und das bezeigt uns
wie unfassbar nah dieser Kampfjet
stattfindet also wie wirklich nur einige
Meter entfernt jetzt kann man noch mal
raussuchen und das ganze uns angucken
der Soldat wirft also denn die Granate
und kurz danach explodiert sie auch
neben ihm das heißt die russischen
Angreifer sind hier keine 10 20 m
entfernt von dieser ukrainischen
Stellung und so muss man sich wirklich
diesen Krieg hier vorstellen der um die
Städte tobt rubigene es war einigen
Tagen an die Russen verloren gegangen
andere Städte werden weiterhin gehalten
von der Ukraine und werden so umkämpft
in dieser Art und Weise
wir wollen es auch neue Aufnahmen
ansehen die uns erreicht haben aus der
Region saporisha saporisha also etwas
weiter südlich auch dort toben die
Kämpfe weiter und was wir hier sehen ist
etwas was wir eigentlich schon mal
gesehen haben nämlich wir sehen
Kampfhubschrauber
bzw das ein Mi 8 Hubschrauber gleich
kommt ein mi24 Hubschrauber die diese
seltsame Taktik anwenden nämlich sehr
flach zu fliegen dann nach oben und kurz
abzuheben Raketen abzuschießen und dann
schnell wieder Entdeckung zu fliegen das
machen sie damit sie natürlich nicht vom
gegnerischen Raketen getroffen werden
hier sehen wir das noch mal das gleiche
ami24 Kampfhubschrauber auch der
feuerdraketen ab und danach geht es sehr
schnell wieder nach unten dass er
sozusagen vom Gegner nicht getroffen
wird das Besondere daran ist dass das
hier ukrainische Hubschrauber sind das
heißt die ukrainische Luftwaffe die von
Putin bereits seit zwei Monaten als
Zitat zu 100% zerstört gelistet wird ist
wieder im Einsatz ist mittlerweile im
Osten des Landes wieder im Einsatz und
beschießt dort russische Stellung diese
Strategie wir haben gesagt dieses flache
fliegen
dann hochsteigen die Raketen abschießen
kann das hier nochmal zeigen hier also
die Raketen die abgeschossen werden hier
sehen wir verschiedene davon und dann
wieder runter zu fliegen das haben die
Ukrainer sich wenn man so möchte von den
Russen abgeguckt in die Russen machen
das schon seit einigen Wochen dass sie
in dieser Art und Weise die Angriffe
vorüben aber das überhaupt die Ukrainer
dazu in der Lage sind noch dass die
Ukraine ein weiterer Hubschrauber und
wir sehen auch Flugzeugen in den letzten
Tagen vermehrt wieder an der Front haben
auch hier wieder das ist etwas was die
russische Propaganda bereits seit Wochen
verneint hat und was aber wiederum
stattfindet das heißt die ukrainische
Luftwaffe ist weiterhin aktiv die
Lufthoheit Putins ist keinesfalls
gegeben und beide Seiten nutzen
mittlerweile ihre Hubschrauber und ihre
Flugzeuge ja wie soll man sagen als so
eine Art Katapulte die also die
ungelenkten Raketen von Nades Bodens auf
den Gegner abschießen und dann wieder an
Sicherheit fliegen
und wie
verzweifelt die Lage mittlerweile für
Putin ist zeigen die letzten Bilder die
wir zeigen wollen wir haben vom
britischen Geheimdienst gestern gehört
dass etwa ein Drittel der Invasionsarmee
mittlerweile ausgefallen ist ein Drittel
hat Putin verloren entweder aufgrund
dessen dass diese Menschen so tot sind
dass Sie dass die russischen Soldaten
gestorben sind etwa 20.000 bis 25.000
schätzt man weitere 20 30.000 sind aber
auch so schwer verletzt dass sie nicht
mehr kämpfen können das heißt von dieser
200.000 Mann Armee die Putin am Anfang
vorbereitet hat ja ist ein Drittel nicht
mehr einsatzbereit was macht Putin jetzt
man kann es kaum glauben er holt
freiwillige Freiwillige aus
Tschetschenien das sind ganz offizielle
Aufnahmen hier vom Flughafen Grozny
Flughafen grossny wo gestern sich
tausende tschetschenische freiwillige
aufgemacht haben die wie es heißt ein
Sondertraining bekommen haben einige
Wochen Wochen an der Waffe ein Training
bekommen haben und jetzt in den Krieg
geschickt werden in die Ukraine die
russische Luftwaffe mit ihr 76 fährt
hier diese die Kämpfer und wir sehen das
einfach mal das sind teilweise Leute die
kommen aus irgendwelchen Dörfern die
sehen zum ersten Mal eine Waffe die
haben überhaupt gar keine Ahnung was auf
sie zukommt aber so weit ist es
mittlerweile so weit ist der stand dass
eben Russland um seine extrem hohen
Verluste in der Ukraine irgendwie wieder
gut zu machen nimmt man zum einen
Söldner der Gruppe Wagner wir wissen das
immer mehr söldnamen Einsatz sind die
aus Afrika zurückgekommen sind aus
Libyen aus aus Syrien im Nahen Osten aus
Mali und so weiter die mittlerweile hier
in Ukraine kämpfen und wir sehen uns
hier ja siegessicher aber eben auch
völlig ja unbedarft gehen hier tausende
tschetschenische ländliche Bewohner in
die Maschinen der russischen Luftwaffe
werden in Richtung Ukraine geflogen und
sollen dann dort ganz offenbar als
Kanonenfutter für Putins stecken
gebliebene Militäroffensive im Osten des
Landes herhalten so also der Stand heute
Tag 81 des Krieges wir sehen es bleibt
dort extrem interessant